This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of the most iconic characters in children's stories are talking animals. What's up, Jack? I told I told Puri Kee! Just keep swimming, just keep swimming, just keep swimming! The wonderful thing about children is to give the wonderful food to the top of the tomato, the rubber, the bottom of the tomato. As children, we love to imagine that animals think as we think and do as we do. We continue to love animal videos as we get older.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。儿童故事中许多最具标志性的角色都是会说话的动物。怎么了，杰克？我告诉过你，我告诉过普里·基！继续游，继续游，继续游！孩子们最棒的地方在于，他们会把美味的食物分给番茄顶端、橡胶，还有番茄底部。作为孩子，我们喜欢想象动物像我们一样思考，像我们一样行事。随着年龄增长，我们依然喜爱动物视频。
If you need evidence, look at YouTube. Maybe you're responsible for one of the 22 million views of this video. Just like to open wide, sir. Okay, I think you're... One monkey lies flat with its mouth wide open. A second monkey hunches over the first, peering into its mouth. It's pretty typical stuff for monkeys. Animals groom each other all the time.
如果你需要证据，看看YouTube就知道了。也许这个视频的2200万次观看中，就有你的一份功劳。先生，请张大嘴。好的，我想你……一只猴子平躺着，嘴巴张得大大的。另一只猴子弯腰俯在第一只猴子身上，盯着它的嘴里看。这对猴子来说是很平常的事。动物们总是互相梳理毛发。
But this video went viral for one very clear reason, the human voiceovers. Are you going anywhere nice on your holidays? Yeah, yeah, don't try and talk one of my hands when you're in your mouth, sir. The voices turn an ordinary occurrence in the animal world into a conversation between a dentist and a patient, except this dentist's office is in a tree
但这个视频走红有一个非常明确的原因，那就是人类的配音。假期打算去什么好地方吗？是的，是的，先生，当我还在你嘴里工作时，别试着说话。这些配音将动物世界中一件平常的事情变成了一场牙医与病人的对话，只不过这位牙医的诊所在树上。
and both doctorate and patient are monkeys. I do the fill in here, actually, at the back. Is it mainly bananas you ate? Hello, sir. I won't tell you again, sir. Please don't try and speak when I'm working inside your mouth. This is just one part of the viral video. There are pelicans that look like they're laughing. I won't tell you again so please don't transpeak when I work inside your mouth. This is just one part of the viral video. There are pelicans that look like they're laughing,
而且牙医和病人都是猴子。其实我是在后面补牙。你主要是吃香蕉吗？你好，先生。我不会再告诉你一遍了，先生。请不要在我嘴里工作时试着说话。这只是这个病毒式视频的一部分。还有看起来像是在笑的鹈鹕。我不会再告诉你一遍了，所以请不要在我嘴里工作时试着说话。这只是这个病毒式视频的一部分。还有看起来像是在笑的鹈鹕，
a squirrel that's beatboxing, two owls that complain they've had too much coffee. I can't even blink anymore and I can hear my heartbeat to my ears, I don't get it, Mary had the same as me, and she went to bed. The joke here is that only humans are supposed to do stuff like this. Although we love anthropomorphized animals, we don't actually believe that other creatures think like us, care about the things we care about, or act the way we do. When animals behave like people, we find it hilarious. In recent years, scientists have begun to actively ask, is what happens in our minds,
一只在口技表演的松鼠，两只抱怨咖啡喝太多的猫头鹰。我甚至没法眨眼了，我能听到自己的心跳声，我不明白，玛丽和我喝的一样，她已经去睡觉了。这里的笑点在于，只有人类才会被认为会做这种事。虽然我们喜欢拟人化的动物，但我们并不真的认为其他生物会像我们一样思考，关心我们在意的事情，或者像我们一样行事。当动物表现得像人时，我们觉得非常滑稽。近年来，科学家们开始积极地探究：我们大脑中发生的事情，
really that different from what happens in the minds of other animals. Researchers working with non-human primates are finding areas of connection as well as important areas of difference. This week on Hidden Brain, what other animals can teach us about us. It was dangerous just to smell your breath. Oh, oh, that is rank. I think I need to lie down. Yale University psychologist Laurie Santos has a long commute between her home in Connecticut and her lab. It's so far that it takes three forms of transportation
真的与动物大脑中发生的事情有那么大不同吗？研究非人类灵长类动物的研究人员正在发现它们之间的联系以及重要的差异。本周的《Hidden Brain》，其他动物能教给我们关于我们自己的什么。闻你的口气简直太危险了。哦，哦，那真是太臭了。我想我需要躺下。耶鲁大学心理学家劳里·桑托斯在康涅狄格州的家和她的实验室之间有很长的通勤路程。路程太远，需要三种交通工具，
and the better part of a day to get there. But there's no need to feel sorry for her. Laurie's lab is a Caribbean island. Kayo Santiago. It's this beautiful island right off the southeast coast of Puerto Rico. To get there, she flies to San Juan, drives about an hour to the small town of Punta Santiago, and then hops in a motorboat.
还要花上一天的大部分时间才能到达。但没必要为她感到遗憾。劳里的实验室是一个加勒比海岛——圣地亚哥岛。它就在波多黎各东南海岸外，是一个美丽的岛屿。为了到达那里，她先飞往圣胡安，开车大约一小时到蓬塔圣地亚哥小镇，然后跳上一艘摩托艇。
Not long after she arrives on the dock, she's surrounded by monkeys. The sandy colored creatures are everywhere, some lounging around, others jumping off a tall branch into the water below. About a thousand, free-ranginganging Reese's monkeys live on this island. And there are monkeys that have been used in research for the last 80 years, and so they're incredibly habituated to humans, which means we can go down there and test monkeys in this natural setting, much like we would test human subjects. So you and your team simply walk out onto the island with your clipboards looking for Reese's
她到达码头后不久，就被猴子包围了。这些沙色的生物随处可见，有的在闲逛，有的从高高的树枝跳进下面的水里。大约有一千只自由放养的恒河猴生活在这个岛上。这些猴子在过去80年里一直被用于研究，所以它们对人类非常习惯，这意味着我们可以去那里，在自然环境中测试猴子，就像我们测试人类受试者一样。所以你和你的团队只是带着剪贴板走上岛，寻找恒河猴
monkeys to study? That's exactly right and we kind of you know find ones that look kind of bored and like they might be willing to do something and we plop down and run studies with them How do you get the animals to sit still and take part in the experiment? Why would why would they want to sign up? Well, they're naturally curious animals, you know, and usually many of the studies involve You know showing the monkeys something really interesting or something really unexpected. It's kind of like a little roving, you know, theater show that shows up when they're sitting there eating, they're like, okay, you know, what are you going to show me? Not all the monkeys sit there, you know, so we definitely
来研究吗？完全正确，我们找到那些看起来有点无聊、好像愿意做点什么的猴子，然后坐下来对它们进行研究。你是怎么让动物坐着不动并参与实验的？它们为什么要报名参加？嗯，它们天生就是好奇的动物，你知道，通常许多研究都涉及向猴子展示一些非常有趣或非常出乎意料的东西。这就像是一个小型的巡回演出，当它们坐在那里吃东西时，它们会想，好吧，你要给我看什么？并不是所有的猴子都会坐在那里，所以我们肯定
get some who kind of walk away and don't want to deal with this, but many are interested enough to stick around. Lori Santos has spent most of her career trying to capture the attention of monkeys, not because she's especially excited about monkeys. She didn't come to this work after a childhood of being obsessed with curious George. No, Lori is fascinated by humans. There's no way to study what makes humans special if you only study humans. You actually have to turn to all the other critters in the animal kingdom.
会遇到一些走开不想理会我们的猴子，但很多猴子感兴趣到愿意留下来。劳里·桑托斯职业生涯的大部分时间都在试图吸引猴子的注意力，并不是因为她对猴子特别兴奋。她并不是因为童年对《好奇的乔治》着迷才从事这项工作的。不，劳里对人类着迷。如果你只研究人类，就无法研究是什么让人类变得特别。你实际上必须转向动物王国里的所有其他生物。
Monkeys are a really important population because they can tell us the kinds of things that are unique to the human species. You can get very valuable information by comparing monkey minds with human minds. Doing this can help us distinguish between things in our heads that are the product of nurture from things in our heads that are the product of nature. You know, we have lots of human culture, we have lots of human teaching. You know, if we're really looking for the pure things that the human mind has, and the absence of those different processes, it's not great to study adult humans.
猴子是一个非常重要的群体，因为它们可以告诉我们哪些是人类物种所独有的。通过比较猴子的大脑和人类的大脑，你可以获得非常有价值的信息。这样做可以帮助我们区分大脑中哪些是后天培养的产物，哪些是先天遗传的产物。你知道，我们有很多人类文化，很多人类教学。如果我们真的在寻找人类大脑纯粹的东西，在没有这些不同过程的情况下，研究成年人类并不是最好的选择。
Now, presumably it would be easier if you could actually study human ancestors, if you could go back and look at human beings who lived several hundred thousand years ago, but they're not around anymore to run research experiments on. Yeah, that's the joke. We come undergrad study pools to see if there are any underthals or homo erectus, and they're not there. It'd be fantastic to study them, but honestly, for many of the things that we've been studying, these basic aspects of social cognition or these basic aspects of decision making, these are capacities that are old enough that you might expect them to be shared with our common ancestor with Rhesus monkeys, say. And so in some ways for the particular cognitive capacities we're studying,
现在，如果能研究人类祖先，如果能回到过去看看几十万年前生活的人类，那可能会更容易，但他们已经不存在了，无法进行研究实验。是的，这就是笑话。我们去本科生研究池看看有没有尼安德特人或直立人，但他们不在那里。研究他们会很棒，但老实说，对于我们一直在研究的许多事情，比如社会认知的基本方面或决策的基本方面，这些能力已经足够古老，你可能会期望它们与我们和恒河猴的共同祖先所共有。所以从某种程度上说，对于我们正在研究的特定认知能力，
you know, it's good to kind of rewind the evolutionary tape as it were as far back as we can. I want to get your experiments in a moment, but just being on this island is apparently revealed all kinds of similarities between humans and other animals. One problem you've had to guard against on the island is unethical behavior. Tell me about the monkey thieves that you've encountered on Kaya Santiago. Well, it's kind of sad to admit that you're getting ripped off by monkeys, but it happens more than you'd think on the island. There are wily creatures who are often pretty hungry,
你知道，尽可能地倒带进化磁带是很好的。我想稍后再谈你的实验，但仅仅是在这个岛上，显然就揭示了人类和其他动物之间的各种相似之处。你在岛上必须防范的一个问题是不道德行为。跟我说说你在圣地亚哥岛遇到的猴子小偷。嗯，承认被猴子抢劫有点可悲，但这在岛上发生的次数比你想象的要多。它们是狡猾的生物，通常很饿，
and humans have backpacks filled with things like lunches and delicious fruit objects for studies and so on. And one of the big inspirations for some of the work we were trying to do on deception and how monkeys think about other minds came from this active theft on behalf of one of the monkeys. We were running a study about number
而人类的背包里装满了午餐和美味的水果等研究用品。我们试图在欺骗以及猴子如何思考他人思想方面所做的一些工作，其灵感很大程度上来自于其中一只猴子的这种主动盗窃行为。我们当时正在进行一项关于数字的研究，
where we were showing monkeys different numbers of objects. And there was one research day that we actually had to go home from the island early because the monkeys had ripped off all of the fruit we were using to display the numbers in the study. And I think it was really on that boat ride home that I started thinking, you know, they're doing this in a successful way. You know, it's not just that we're done researchers and they can outsmart us. They're specifically trying to steal from us when we're not aware of what they're doing
我们向猴子展示不同数量的物体。有一天，我们不得不提前从岛上回家，因为猴子抢走了我们用来展示研究数字的所有水果。我想就是在回程的船上，我开始思考，你知道，它们成功地做到了这一点。你知道，这不仅仅是我们研究人员笨，它们能智胜我们。它们是在我们不知道它们在做什么时，
or maybe even when we have a false belief about what they're doing. And so it really launched this line of research to be like, okay, how are they thinking about that problem, you know, that they're doping us in? You know, what are the representations they're using to solve this task? And is it true that they are not just simply stealing, but in some ways going after the easiest targets,
甚至在我们对它们在做什么有错误信念时，专门试图从我们这里偷东西。所以这确实开启了这一研究方向，去探究：好吧，它们是如何思考那个问题的？它们在用什么表征来解决这个任务？它们不仅仅是简单的偷窃，而是在某种程度上寻找最容易的目标，这是否属实？
in some ways what criminologists might call a rational model of crime? Yeah, and lots of ways. In fact, we set this up as a study. This was work, early work that I did with John Flombum. We basically set up an experiment where we gave monkeys the opportunity to steal rationally. What we did was we had them experience, they're kind of walking around and they see two people
在某种程度上，这是否就是犯罪学家所说的理性犯罪模型？是的，在很多方面。事实上，我们把它设定为一项研究。这是我早期与约翰·弗隆布姆一起做的工作。我们基本上做了一个实验，让猴子有机会理性地偷窃。我们所做的是让他们体验，他们四处走动，看到两个人
who are standing in front of a grape, which is a tasty piece of food for monkeys. One of those people is kind of looking at the grapes. If you tried to steal it, he'd probably stop you, whereas the other person is not paying attention, either because he's turned around or he has a barrier in front of his face and so on. And we just gave monkeys one trial.
站在一颗葡萄前，这对猴子来说是一种美味的食物。其中一个人在看着葡萄。如果你试图偷它，他可能会阻止你，而另一个人没有注意，要么是因为他转过身去了，要么是因为他面前有障碍物等等。我们只给了猴子一次尝试的机会。
And what we found is that even on that first trial, monkeys selectively stole from the person who couldn't see them. In other words, they're rationally calculating, you know, whether or not someone could detect that they're about to do something dastardly. That's fascinating. And you've done some experiments, reviewing some fairly sophisticated things that the monkeys are doing, including things involving basic math.
我们发现，即使在第一次尝试中，猴子也会有选择地从看不见它们的人那里偷东西。换句话说，它们在理性地计算某人是否能察觉到它们即将做坏事。这太迷人了。你做了一些实验，回顾了猴子正在做的一些相当复杂的事情，包括涉及基础数学的事情。
Can you tell me about some of the experiments where you've tested whether the monkeys have an ability to count, a very simple counting, for example? Yeah, so this is some early work that was done at the field site back when I was a, no, no graduate, actually. It was studies that were really trying to see whether or not monkeys shared the basic capacities that human infants seem to have. This is worked by Karen Winn and her colleagues at Yale. She found that even by about six months of age babies can track the outcomes of arithmetic events.
你能告诉我一些你测试猴子是否有计数能力（例如非常简单的计数）的实验吗？是的，这是我在研究生时期在实地考察点做的一些早期工作。这些研究确实是在试图观察猴子是否拥有人类婴儿似乎拥有的基本能力。这是凯伦·温和她在耶鲁大学的同事们的工作。她发现，即使在六个月大时，婴儿也能追踪算术事件的结果。
So if baby see one object added to a box and that box is covered up and a second object is put in, they seem to expect exactly two objects will be in the box. And they seem to be surprised when the box is open to reveal only one object or three objects. And so we can do the same kinds of studies out in the field with the monkeys. We literally set up a little magical box for the monkeys. We put out a little monkey magician hats and head out.
所以，如果婴儿看到一个物体被放入盒子里，盒子被盖住，然后放入第二个物体，它们似乎期望盒子里正好有两个物体。当盒子打开只露出一个物体或三个物体时，它们似乎会感到惊讶。所以我们可以在实地对猴子进行同样的实验。我们真的为猴子设置了一个小小的魔法盒。我们戴上小猴子魔术师帽，出发了。
And then show the magic tricks. The magic isn't all that exciting. We're putting one or two plants into a box and revealing different outcomes. I can give you my magician secrets if you need them. But basically what we found is that monkeys show exactly the same performance on these studies as human infants. In other words, they expect the outcome of one plus one to be exactly two. And they're, they expect the outcome of one plus one to be exactly two, and they're surprised if they see three or one. And in some ways it's interesting the connection you're making between studying monkeys and studying infants, because in some ways they both tell us when you study a child, a small
然后展示魔术。魔术并不那么令人兴奋。我们把一个或两个物体放入盒子里，揭示不同的结果。如果你需要的话，我可以告诉你我的魔术师秘密。但基本上我们发现，猴子在这些研究中的表现与人类婴儿完全相同。换句话说，它们期望一加一的结果正好是二。当它们看到三或一时，它们会感到惊讶。从某种程度上说，你将研究猴子和研究婴儿联系起来很有趣，因为在某种程度上，它们都告诉我们，当你研究一个孩子、一个小孩、一个婴儿，看到这种基本的数学技能时，它实际上告诉你，你并不需要去学校学习那种基础数学。
child, an infant, and you see this kind of rudimentary math skills, it actually tells you you don't actually have to go to school to learn that basic math. some of that is actually potentially programmed into how the brain operates. That's right, it's yet another way of kind of removing all the training and teaching and cultural learning that we humans have. If you turn to human infants, what you find is capacities that are there in the absence of experience, right? In the absence of very little experience. These studies suggest that there are more similarities than we imagine right? In the absence of very little experience. These studies suggest that there are more similarities than we imagine between humans and other animals. They challenge our assumption that the human mind is unique. For example,
其中一些实际上可能已经编程到大脑的运作方式中了。没错，这是消除我们人类所拥有的所有训练、教学和文化学习的另一种方式。如果你转向人类婴儿，你会发现这些能力在没有经验的情况下就存在，对吧？在几乎没有经验的情况下。这些研究表明，人类和其他动物之间的相似之处比我们想象的要多，对吧？它们挑战了我们关于人类大脑是独一无二的假设。例如，
Laurie says, one long-standing belief was that non-human primates were bad at thinking about other animals' perspectives. Even our closest living relative chimpanzees had failed on really simple tasks where a human's trying to get the chimpanzee to look for food in one particular location, there's a bunch of cups that are turned over, and the human would point at one of these overturned cups. And what the research showed is that primates were really bad at this task. They didn't seem to realize that pointing meant some information that a human was trying to communicate with you. And this really led to the view that primates were bad at
劳里说，一个长期存在的信念是，非人类灵长类动物不善于思考其他动物的观点。即使是我们最近的现存亲戚黑猩猩，在一些非常简单的任务上也失败了，比如人类试图让黑猩猩在特定位置寻找食物，那里有一堆倒扣的杯子，人类会指向其中一个倒扣的杯子。研究表明，灵长类动物在这个任务上表现非常糟糕。它们似乎没有意识到指向意味着人类试图与你交流某种信息。这确实导致了一种观点，即灵长类动物不善于
understanding others' perspectives. They didn't seem to know what other individuals knew. And that line of research kind of, it didn't really settle well with a lot of the people who are watching primates in the field, you know, like, you know, it's bad to be reading this paper that primates don't understand other people's perspective when you're getting ripped off every day on this island and have to go home early. And so, you know, so that was what launched a lot of our studies and other studies by
理解他人的观点。它们似乎不知道其他人知道什么。而那一研究方向，对于许多在实地观察灵长类动物的人来说，并不是很令人信服，你知道，当你每天在岛上被抢劫并不得不提前回家时，读到这篇关于灵长类动物不理解他人观点的论文感觉很糟糕。所以，这就是启动我们许多研究的原因，以及像布莱恩和同事们所做的其他研究，试图观察非人类灵长类动物在理解他人观点方面拥有什么样的基本能力。作为这些研究的一部分，我们开发了各种各样的东西来测试猴子是否分享我们对他人感知、他人听到和他人知道什么的理解。而所有这些研究大体上似乎都表明，非人类灵长类动物在这方面做得相当不错。
researchers like Brian here and colleagues trying to look at, you know, what are the basic capacities primate, non-human primates have for understanding like what other people's perspectives are. And as part of these studies, we've developed all kinds of different things to test whether monkeys share our understanding of what others perceive, what others hear, and what others know. And all of those studies by and large seem to be showing that non-human primates are pretty good at that.
它们似乎知道一些关于他人观点的事情。你能给我一两个例子说明这些研究是什么以及它们发现了什么吗？是的，其中一项研究同样建立在对人类婴儿进行的研究之上。这是一项观察人类婴儿是否预测一个人会去她知道物体所在的地方拿取的研究。想象一下以下场景，
They seem to know something about someone else's perspective. Can you give me one or two examples of what these studies are and what they find? Yeah, one of the studies was, again, built off a study that had been done in human infants. This was a study looking at whether or not human infants predict that a person will reach where she knows an object is. So imagine the following scenario,
你正在观察一个似乎非常喜欢特定物体的人，有一个玩具是他们非常感兴趣的。那个玩具滚落并掉进了两个盒子中的一个。问题是你期望那个人去哪里拿？你可能会期望她去她知道玩具所在的那个盒子里拿。人们会在他们认为东西所在的地方去拿东西。
you're watching somebody who seems to really like a particular object, there's a toy that they're really interested in. And that toy rolls over and falls into one of two boxes. Question is where do you expect that person to reach? You probably expect her to reach in the box where she knows it to be. People reach for things where they think they are.
这就是研究在婴儿身上发现的结果。如果那个看到玩具滚进一个盒子的人去另一个盒子找玩具，婴儿会感到惊讶。我们只是把同样的研究引入了猴子身上。我们让猴子看着一个人渴望地看着一个美味的苹果，然后它们看到那个苹果移动到了一个特定的盒子里。
And that's what the research found with babies. Babies are surprised if that person who saw a toy roll into one box reaches into a different box to look for the toy. We just imported that same study for monkeys. We had monkeys watch as a human looked longingly at a delicious apple, and then they saw that apple move into a particular box.
我们证明了，如果一个人看到苹果移动到一个盒子里，却看向相反的位置，猴子会感到惊讶。它们似乎期望一个人去他们知道东西所在的地方拿东西。稍后回来，更多关于劳里的实验以及它们可能告诉我们关于人类大脑的信息。在夏天，心理学家劳里·桑托斯将她的研究带到了户外。在棕榈树和阳光下，她在圣地亚哥岛研究恒河猴。但这只是她研究的一个场景。十年来，她还在她建立的实验室里研究猴子
And we showed that the monkeys are surprised if when a person sees an apple move into a box, they look to the opposite location. They kind of expect a person to reach for something where they know it's going to be. When we come back, more from Laurie's experiments and what they may tell us about the human mind. During the summer, psychologist Laurie Santos takes her research outdoors. Under palm trees and sunshine, she studies Rises Monkeys on the island of Kaya Santiago. But that's only one setting for her research. For a decade, she also studied monkeys at a lab she built
在耶鲁大学。与波多黎各的恒河猴不同，耶鲁的猴子是卷尾猴。我们主要选择不同的物种，因为在某种程度上，卷尾猴在圈养中非常容易进行社会化安置。所以你可以把它们放在一个大的动物园围栏里，它们非常舒适。这就是我们选择该物种的原因之一。
at Yale University. Unlike the recess monkeys in Puerto Rico, the monkeys at Yale were capuchins. We mostly chose different species because in some ways capuchins are very easy to kind of house socially in captivity. So you can have them in kind of a big zoo enclosure and they're very comfortable. And that was one of the reasons we picked that species.
第二个原因是，对于卷尾猴，我们想研究一系列不同的问题，我们做了关于它们对他人观点了解的工作，但我们也想研究它们的决策策略。有很多研究表明，卷尾猴非常擅长做决定和使用工具，特别是它们擅长一种我们非常想使用的方法，那就是涉及代币交易的方法，猴子可以用代币向我们购买不同的商品和服务。
A second reason was that with the capuchins we wanted to look at a set of different questions we did work on what they know about others' perspectives, but we also wanted to look at their decision-making strategies. And there was lots of work showing that Capuchins were really good at kind of making decisions and using tools, but in particular that they were good at a method that we really wanted to use, which was a method involving token trading where monkeys could pay us for different goods and services.
有很多研究表明卷尾猴可能擅长这一点。我们认为这可能是一个有趣的途径，可以开始观察一些猴子的经济决策。劳里创造了她所谓的“猴子市场”。她想教猴子使用货币。我的意思是，当我们第一次开始谈论这些研究时，你知道，对朋友们说，他们会说，你要教猴子使用货币。我的意思是，当我们第一次开始谈论这些研究时，你知道，对朋友们说，他们会说，你要教猴子使用货币。我说，你知道，这听起来很疯狂，但事实上，让猴子进行这种交易非常简单。
There was lots of work suggesting that capuchins might be good at that. And we thought that might be an interesting avenue to start looking at some of monkeys' economic decision making. Laurie created what she called a monkey marketplace. She wanted to teach monkeys to use money. I mean, when we first started talking about these studies, you know, to friends and stuff, they're like, you're going to teach monkeys to use money. I mean, when we first started talking about these studies, you know, to friends and stuff, they're like, you're going to teach monkeys to use money. And I was like, you know, it sounds crazy, but in fact, it's pretty simple to get them monkeys to do this kind of trading.
它们天生就是非常好奇的生物。所以一开始，我们只是把小金属代币放在它们的围栏里，它们看起来就像，你知道，假钱。卷尾猴会自然地捡起这些东西，但它们对这些东西没有任何用处。它们很快意识到，如果把它们交还给人类实验者，我们就会给猴子一块食物作为代币的回报。所以这就像是一种代币换食物的交换。令人惊讶的是，猴子非常快地学会了这一点。仅仅几次接触后，它们就意识到，哦，等等，我用代币换食物，明白了。一旦它们学会了这一点，我们就可以询问关于它们对真实市场了解的各种经济问题。
They're naturally really curious critters. And so at the start, we just put inside their enclosure, little metal tokens, they kind of looked like, you know, little fake pieces of money. And the kitchens would naturally pick these up, but they kind these up, but they didn't have any use for them. And they quickly realized that if they handed them back to a human experimenter, we'd give the monkeys back a piece of food for the token. So it was kind of like a token for a piece of food sort
一旦猴子学会了代币就是货币，它们就开始寻找便宜货。我们做的第一件事是给它们机会寻找划算的交易，这意味着让它们在以不同价格提供的不同商品之间做出选择。所以“猴子市场”就是当猴子从它们的大型社会围栏里出来进行测试，进入一个较小的围栏时，
of exchange. And what was surprising is that the monkeys picked this up incredibly quickly. Within just a few exposures, they realized, oh, wait, I give tokens for food, got it. And then once we had them doing that, we could ask all kinds of economic questions about what they knew about real markets.
它们可以接触到其中一些代币。然后猴子可以在两个以不同价格出售不同商品的实验者之间做出选择。所以有人可能以一个代币出售葡萄柚，而有人可能以一个代币出售黄瓜。问题是猴子是否最大化了它们的食物美元。考虑到它们得到的食物量和食物种类，它们购物是否理性？
Once the monkeys learned the tokens were currency, they began hunting for bargains. The first thing we did was give them opportunities to find good deals, and that meant giving them a choice between different goods offered at different prices. So the monkey marketplace was when the monkeys, they came in for testing from their big social enclosure and entered a little smaller enclosure
我们发现令人惊奇的是，猴子在这个市场上似乎相对理性。也就是说，它们似乎理性地进行替代。它们用代币美元购买了更多的食物，而且它们似乎更喜欢购买它们更喜欢的食物。你认为它们真的享受购物的过程吗？我的意思是，正如你所知，一些人类，实际上很多人类确实享受去商店买东西的过程。这其中有乐趣吗？因为当然，猴子在这里做的不仅仅是
where they had access to a few of these tokens. And then monkeys had a choice between two experimenters who sold different goods at different prices. So someone might be selling a grapefruit one token and someone might be selling, say, a cucumber for one token. And the question was whether the monkeys maximized their food dollar, as it were. Did they shop rationally given the amount to food that they were getting and the kind of food?
我参与了一个实验，我按下一个杠杆，然后得到一些食物。在这种情况下，你实际上可以做出选择。我可以去找A，也可以去找B。我有选择权。作为消费者，我有自主权。是的，很难说。我的意思是，我们没有直接衡量快乐的经验指标，但它们确实看起来很喜欢。
And the amazing thing that we've found is that the monkeys seem to be relatively rational in this market. That is, they seem to substitute rationally. They bought more food with their token dollar, and they seem to prefer shopping for foods that they liked better Did they actually you think enjoy the process of shopping? I mean some humans as you know sort of lots of humans actually enjoy the process of going to a store and buying things What was there a pleasure and sort of doing this because of course what the monkeys were doing here is not just simply
你知道，它们会冲进围栏尝试这样做。我最喜欢的是，它们倾向于非常关注不同的选择是什么。它们会走到围栏的两边，非常仔细地观察每个实验者提供的东西，所以它们看起来是非常细心的购物者。我想知道猴子是否会互相交易代币，它们会说，你知道，我付给你三个代币让你给我梳理毛发吗？是的，你知道，非凡的事情是猴子从来没有真正那样做过。我的意思是，公平地说，我们没有给它们机会那样做，你知道，因为它们大部分时间都是自己拿着代币。但引人注目的是，猴子似乎不需要在它们自己的社会系统中建立代币经济。它们有一种行之有效的经济。它们有这种非常严格的支配等级制度。这决定了谁能获得商品和服务。所以换句话说，你知道，如果你是一只低等级的雄性，你有一大钱包代币，如果
I'm part of an experiment where I press You know I press a lever and I get some food. In this case, you actually can choose. I can go to Person A or I can go to Person B. I have choices. I have autonomy as a consumer. Yeah, it's hard. I mean, we didn't have a direct empirical measure of pleasure, but they really did seem to like it.
阿尔法雄性看到了，你可能会自然地放手让它拿走，因为那是你所属的社会系统。这相当于人类封建时代的系统，只有某些人才能获得商品和服务。所以从某种程度上说，它教会了我们，你知道，要成为一个使用货币的物种，你必须是一个相对平等的物种。劳里想回答的下一个问题触及了人类如何做出经济决策的核心。
You know, they would rush into the enclosure to try to do this. And what I loved most is that they tend to pay a lot of attention to what the different options were. They'd kind of go on both sides of the enclosure and look at what each experiment was offering very carefully so they seem to be it very like careful shoppers I'm wondering whether the monkeys ever traded tokens with each other did they say you know I'm going to pay you three tokens for you to groom me yeah well you know the remarkable thing is that the monkeys never really did that I mean to be fair we fair, we didn't give them opportunities to do that, you know, because they were kind of with the tokens mostly by themselves. But what's striking is it doesn't seem like the monkeys maybe need a token economy in their own social system. They kind of have an economy that works. They have this really strict dominant hierarchy. And that determines who gets goods and services. So in other words, you know, if you're a low ranking male and you had a big wallet of tokens, if
经济学长期以来一直建立在人类在涉及金钱时是理性的这一理念之上。但我们现在有大量证据表明情况往往并非如此。人类是一个了不起的物种，但拿起任何一本《经济学人》杂志，你就会发现我们在金钱方面并不擅长。我们经常搞砸。我们过度关注损失和风险。我们不一定理性地投资。我们经常搞砸。我们过度关注损失和风险。我们不一定理性地投资。研究人员发现了一套人类在市场上表现出的标准认知偏差。
the alpha male saw that, you might kind of naturally let them go and let him take it, because that's the social system you're part of. It's equivalent to human systems of back in the days of feudalism and these kinds of things where only certain individuals are supposed to get access to goods and services. So in some ways, it kind of taught us that, you know, to be a species that uses money, you really have to be a relatively egalitarian species. One of the next questions Laurie wanted to answer gets at the heart of how humans make economic decisions.
所以我们想利用猴子市场来看看猴子是否像人类一样有偏见。为了做到这一点，我们给了它们客观上产生相似结果的选择，所以它们会得到相同数量的食物。但这些选择的框架不同。基本上，我们借鉴了人类心理学中丹尼·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基等人的经典工作，他们给人们的问题是将事物框架为收益或损失。
Economics has long rested on the idea that humans are rational when money is involved. But we now have plenty of evidence that this often isn't the case. Humans are amazing species, but pick up any article of the economist and you figure out that we're not great at money. We kind of mess up a lot of times. We overpay attention to losses and risk. We don't necessarily invest rationally. We kind of mess up a lot of times. We overpay attention to losses and risk. We don't necessarily invest rationally. And researchers have found a set of standard cognitive biases that humans show in the markets.
丹尼·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基著名地发现，人们对收益和损失的看法并不相同。假设我要给你10美元。在一个场景中，我告诉你我要给你15美元，结果只给了你10美元。在另一个场景中，我告诉你我要给你5美元，结果给了你10美元。在这两种情况下，你收到的金额都是10美元。但感觉不同。在一种情况下，你觉得有什么东西被拿走了。在另一种情况下，你觉得你得到了
And so we wanted to use the monkey market to see if monkeys are biased in the same way as humans are. And to do that, we gave them options that objectively gave them similar outcomes, so they would get the same amount of food. But those options were framed differently. Basically, we're stealing from classic work in human psychology with adult participants from people like Danny Coniman and Amos Tversky, who gave people problems where things were framed as gains or losses.
一点额外的东西。劳里想看看猴子是否会有同样的反应。所以为了做到这一点，我们会向猴子展示一个最终它们会得到两块食物的情况，但那两块食物的框架不同。一个实验者只展示两块食物，猴子得到两块，所以这基本上是它们所期望的，而另一个实验者展示三块食物，然后猴子只得到两块食物。在第二种情况下，你知道，你最终得到的食物量是一样的，但感觉就像你失去了一些东西。我们在这样的研究中发现，猴子
Danny Coniman and Amos Tversky famously found that people don't think of gains and losses the same way. Let's say I was going to give you $10. In one scenario, I tell you I'm going to give you $15 and instead give you $10. In another scenario, I tell you I'm going to give you $5 and instead give you $10. In both scenarios, you receive the same amount, $10. But they feel different. In one case, you feel something's been taken away from you. In the other, you feel like you got a
似乎系统性地避免损失。即使它们得到的食物量相同，它们也会避开那个给它们带来损失感的人。这正是人类在许多标准决策研究中似乎所做的。我们倾向于避免损失，即使它们客观上不是损失，即使它们只是被那样框架。那么如果有人只展示了一件食物，但当猴子支付了一个代币时，猴子得到了两件，这种情况呢？是的，所以猴子似乎也对收益，也就是看起来像收益的东西给予了一点关注。事实上，我们给猴子选择的是它们肯定会得到的收益，也就是确定的收益和有风险的收益。
little extra. Laurie wanted to see if monkeys responded the same way. And so to do that, we would show monkeys a case where ultimately they're gonna get say two pieces of food, but that two pieces of food is framed differently. One experiment or just shows two pieces of food and the monkeys get two, so that's kind of what they expect, whereas another experimenter say shows three pieces of food, and then the monkey only gets two pieces of food. And that second case, you know, you get the same amount of food in the end, but it kind of feels like you lost something. And what we would find in studies like that is that the monkeys
让我给你出卡尼曼和特沃斯基给人类出的那个问题。我首先给你1000美元，这看起来很棒，但现在你必须想办法得到更多的钱。一方面，你可以确定地额外得到500美元，所以你得到1500美元，或者你可以冒险。我要抛硬币，如果是正面，你再得到1000美元，但如果是反面，你什么也得不到。当你把这个问题抛给大多数本科生时，大多数人会选择安全的选择。他们想要确定得到的收益。这就是我们给猴子的问题。我们给了
seem to systematically avoid the loss. Even though they were getting the same amount of food, they would avoid the guy that gave them what felt like a loss. And this is exactly what humans seem to do in a lot of standard decision-making studies. We tend to avoid losses even when they're not objectively lost, even when they're just framed that way. And what about the situation where maybe someone showed only one item of food, but when the monkey paid up a token, the monkey got two. Yeah, and so the monkeys also seem to pay a little bit of attention to gains, what looked like gains. In fact, what we gave the monkeys a choice between was a gain that they would get for sure, so a sure gain and a risky gain.
它们一个选择，在确定收益（它们看到一块食物但知道会得到两块）和风险选项（它们看到一块食物，总是会得到那一块，但可能会以风险方式额外得到两块）之间。所以客观结果完全一样。唯一变化的是风险。我们发现，猴子有选择地选择了那个给它们安全赌注的人。它们像人类一样，在处于看起来像收益的框架情况时避免风险。但当我们把情况更多地变成损失时，一切都变了。所以你可以自己体验一下。你知道，想象一下我先给你2000美元，你的选择是
Let me give you the following problem that was given to humans by comment versus ski. I'm first going to give you $1,000, which seems great, but now you're going to have to figure out a way to get more money. On one hand, you could just get $500 extra with certainty, so you get $1,500, or you could take a risk. I'm going to flip a coin, and if it comes up heads, you get another $1,000, but tails you get nothing. When you pitch this problem to most undergraduates most people pick the safe option there. They want to go with the gain that they get for sure. And that's the problem we gave to monkeys. We gave
如何失去这笔钱。一个选择是你肯定会失去它，所以我直接拿走500美元。但另一个选择是你冒险。我要抛硬币，如果是正面，那很糟糕，你失去1000美元，反面你什么也不失去。所以客观上，金额平均是一样的，你会得到1500美元。但在实践中，现在那种损失看起来很糟糕。大多数人在做出这种选择时，实际上会避免损失。当我们给猴子定性相似的经济情况时，我们发现
them a choice between a sure gain like they they saw one piece of food but new they were gonna get to versus a risky option where they saw one piece of food and they're always gonna get that one but they might get two extra ones in a risky way. So the objective outcome was exactly the same. All that varied was the risk. And what we found was that the monkeys selectively shocked at the person who gave them the safe bet. They like humans avoided risk when they were in a situation that seemed framed like a gain. But all that change when we made the situation more about losses. And so you can experience this yourself. You know imagine I'm gonna start you with two thousand dollars and your choices are how
它们也避免了损失。这就是非理性的。它们根据问题的任意框架方式改变了对风险的选择。换句话说，当它被框架为收益时，它们采取了安全选项。当它被框架为损失时，它们采取了风险选项。完全正确。
to lose this money. One option is that you can lose it with certainty so I just take five hundred dollars away. But another option is that you can take a risk. I'm gonna flip a coin if it comes up heads that's bad, you lose a thousand dollars, tails you lose nothing. And so objectively, the amounts are the same on average, you'll get $1,500. But in practice, now that loss seems kind of yucky. Most people, actually, when given that choice, avoid the loss. And what we found when we gave the monkeys qualitatively similar economic situations is that
令人惊讶的是，这正是我们在房地产市场中看到的同样的偏见。这正是我们在高尔夫球场上看到的同样的偏见。人们在推杆时，如果知道自己会高于标准杆还是低于标准杆，他们的推杆方式实际上是不同的。这似乎是我们人类如何框架世界的基本偏见。这项研究表明，猴子似乎也有同样的偏见。那么像丹尼·卡尼曼这样的研究人员也研究过一种叫做“禀赋效应”的东西。什么是禀赋效应，我们在猴子身上也看到了同样的事情吗？是的，禀赋效应是一种偏见，我们
they also avoided the loss. And that's what's irrational. They're switching their choice about risk, depending on how a problem is arbitrarily framed. In other words, they took the safe option when it was framed as a gain. They took the risky option when it was framed as a loss. That's exactly right.
高估我们拥有的东西。你知道，你家里那个旧沙发，如果有人在eBay上给你出价，他们可能会觉得它有点破旧，但你因为拥有它，觉得它很棒。这是我们在人类文化市场的各个部分看到的偏见。我们想看看猴子是否有这种偏见。我们基本上是给猴子不同的食物。所以现在它们交易的是食物而不是代币。我们想看看猴子是否会为了等价的
And what's surprising is that's exactly the same bias that we see in housing markets. That's the exact same bias that we see on the golf course. People actually put differently when they're putting and they know they're going to go over par versus under par. It seems to be a basic bias we have in how we as humans frame the world. And what this study showed was that monkeys seem to have exactly that same bias. So researchers like Danny Conneman have also studied something called the endowment effect. What is the endowment effect and do we see the same thing among monkeys? Yeah, the endowment effect is a bias where we
食物而放弃它们的那块食物。我们发现它们似乎不想那样做。即使我们提高了赌注，以至于我们给它们的食物比它们拥有的食物价值高出许多倍。在某种程度上，我们非常有兴趣看看能否让猴子把它们的食物换回来，我们给它们提供了一块小葡萄，对比我们称之为“绒毛塔可”的东西，那是一种水果卷，
overvalue things that we own. You know, that old couch that you've had in your house, you know, if somebody were to, you know, offer you some money on eBay, they might think it's kind of, you know, a little ratty, but you think because you own it, it's amazing. This is a bias we see playing out all different parts of the market in human cultures. And we wanted to see whether monkeys had that bias too. What we basically did was to give monkeys different food items. So now they're trading foods rather than tokens. And we wanted to see whether monkeys would give up their piece of food for an equivalent
里面装满了棉花糖绒。这是你在小范围内能给猴子的最甜的东西。即使在那时，它们仍然不会用它们被赋予的食物去换另一块食物。所以，人类和卷尾猴在几千万年前有一个共同的祖先。我们在猴子和人类身上都看到损失厌恶或禀赋效应，这告诉我们什么？我认为这告诉我们，无论我们使用什么认知策略，你知道，当我们去杂货店买食物时，这些机制不仅仅是为使用货币而建立的机制。这些机制是我们用来框架决策的机制，
piece of food. And what we found was that they didn't seem to want to do that. Even when we up the anties, such that the food we were giving them was many, many, many times as valuable as the food that they had. At one level, we were so interested in seeing if we could get the monkeys to trade back their food that we offered them in contrast to a small piece of grape, what we call the fluff taco, which is a fruit roll-up
食物。我们发现它们似乎并不想这样做。即使我们提高了筹码，使我们给它们的食物比它们已有的食物价值高出许多倍。在某种程度上，我们非常想看看能否让猴子把它们的食物换回来，于是我们提供了一种与小块葡萄形成对比的东西，我们称之为“棉花糖塔可”，这是一种水果卷，
filled with marshmallow fluff. It's about the sweetest thing you can offer a monkey in a small go. And even in that case, they still wouldn't trade their piece of food that they were endowed with for a different piece of food. So, humans and Capuchin monkeys shared a common ancestor tens of millions of years ago. What does it tell us that we see loss of version or the endowment effect in monkeys as well as humans? I think it tells us that whatever cognitive strategies we're using, you know, when we go to the grocery store to buy our food, those mechanisms aren't just mechanisms that are built for using money. Like those mechanisms are mechanisms that we've been using to frame decisions for
里面填满了棉花糖。这是你能一次性提供给猴子的最甜的东西。即便如此，它们仍然不愿意用自己拥有的那块食物去交换另一块食物。所以，人类和卷尾猴在几千万年前拥有共同的祖先。我们在猴子和人类身上都看到了损失厌恶或禀赋效应，这说明了什么？我认为这告诉我们，无论我们使用什么样的认知策略，你知道，当我们去杂货店买食物时，这些机制不仅仅是为了使用金钱而建立的。这些机制是我们用来构建决策的机制，
millennia, right? The mechanisms that we use when we're making quick purchases online are the same as the mechanisms monkeys must be using when they're foraging and so on. So I think it tells us that the strategies we're using are really, really old, and that gives us some hints about what those strategies might be for, and whether or not we should really consider them irrational. I was going to ask you that question. I mean, we think of these as being examples of bias or error, but the fact that they're really ancient suggests that perhaps they played
几千年来，对吧？我们在网上快速购物时所使用的机制，与猴子在觅食等活动中所使用的机制是一样的。所以我认为这告诉我们，我们所使用的策略是非常非常古老的，这为我们提供了一些线索，让我们了解这些策略的用途，以及我们是否真的应该认为它们是不理性的。我正想问你这个问题。我的意思是，我们认为这些是偏见或错误的例子，但它们非常古老的事实表明，也许它们发挥了
a useful role, at least in our evolutionary past, if not the present. Yeah, I mean, you'd think if they were that harmful, they would have been selected out. You know, monkeys who use loss of version versus some other bias might not do as well, real monkey markets out there in the evolutionary world. I think that's one possibility. I think when you think about what could a bias like that be useful for, it
某种有用的作用，即使不是在现在，至少在我们的进化史上是这样。是的，我的意思是，你会认为如果它们真的那么有害，它们早就被淘汰了。你知道，使用损失厌恶而不是其他偏见的猴子可能表现得没那么好，在进化世界中存在真正的猴子市场。我认为这是一种可能性。我认为当你思考像这样的偏见有什么用处时，它
turns out that it's hard to think in objective terms in the world. Sometimes there's strategy where you think relative, like relative to someone else's option or relative to a reference point. Those strategies can be better. So imagine the following scenario. You're instantly a Capuchin monkey, and you
结果发现，以客观的角度去思考世界是很困难的。有时存在一种策略，即你进行相对思考，比如相对于别人的选择或相对于一个参考点。这些策略可能会更好。所以想象一下下面的场景。你瞬间变成了一只卷尾猴，你
have to figure out how much food to get today. You're foraging for nuts. How many nuts should you go for, and when should you stop? It's a hard problem. But if you see that I'm walking around with three nuts, and Joe monkeys walking around with three nuts, then maybe shooting for three nuts is pretty good. Maybe if you only get two, you should work a little harder and feel bad.
必须弄清楚今天能得到多少食物。你在寻找坚果。你应该寻找多少个坚果，什么时候应该停止？这是一个难题。但如果你看到我带着三个坚果走来走去，乔猴子也带着三个坚果走来走去，那么也许以三个坚果为目标是相当不错的。也许如果你只得到了两个，你应该更努力一点，并感到难过。
But if you get four, I shouldn't, you know, you don't need to celebrate, that was just good. And so it might be that strategies like loss of version where you really are comparing against other people and then you have mechanisms to motivate you not to go under what other people have. Those might have been more useful than we think. It's just when we throw them into stock markets that they kind of look a little quirky. You know, we had Keith Payne, the psychologist on Hidden Brain recently talking about how inequality works and the psychology of inequality. And in some ways, you and others have found that monkeys exhibit some of the same behavior. They pay very, very close attention as in
但如果你得到了四个，我不应该，你知道，你不需要庆祝，那只是运气好。所以，像损失厌恶这样你确实在与他人进行比较，然后你有机制来激励自己不要低于别人所拥有的策略，可能比我们想象的更有用。只是当我们把它们扔进股票市场时，它们看起来有点古怪。你知道，我们最近在《隐藏的大脑》节目中请到了心理学家基思·佩恩，讨论不平等是如何运作的以及不平等的心理学。在某些方面，你和其他人发现猴子表现出一些相同的行为。它们非常非常密切地关注，正如
the analogy you just gave me to what other monkeys have and whether what they have in relative terms is fair. I think that's right. I mean, there's some classic work by the researchers Sarah Brosnan and Franz DeWall. They find that monkeys don't just pay attention to what other individuals have when they feel like they're getting a raw deal. You know, if you're, I'm like, you who's getting kind of a yucky cucumber when another monkey's getting a grape, you'll actually reject that offer. So it's not just that that monkeys sort of experience things like, hey, that's unfair. They actually act on it in
你刚才给我的类比，关注其他猴子拥有什么，以及它们在相对意义上所拥有的东西是否公平。我认为那是对的。我的意思是，研究人员萨拉·布罗斯南和弗朗茨·德瓦尔做了一些经典的研究。他们发现，当猴子觉得自己在交易中吃亏时，它们不仅仅关注其他个体拥有什么。你知道，如果你是像我一样，得到了一种难吃的黄瓜，而另一只猴子得到了一颗葡萄，你实际上会拒绝那个提议。所以这不仅仅是猴子体验到诸如“嘿，这不公平”之类的感觉。它们实际上会采取行动，
ways that reduce the number of resources they have. When we come back, experiments that show what other animals do differently than us, and the psychological quirks that make us uniquely human. In the 1800s, a British inventor named William Henry Talbot was so caught up in his work that he and his wife had to delay their honeymoon. Eventually, they did go winding their way through Europe to Italy. He was mesmerized by Lake Como with its wishbone shape and its backdrop of the Alps. He was neither the first, nor the last, to be enchanted by the view. It was even a lake that George Lucas used
减少它们拥有的资源数量。回来后，我们将探讨展示其他动物与我们有何不同，以及使我们成为独特人类的心理怪癖的实验。19世纪，一位名叫威廉·亨利·塔尔博特的英国发明家太专注于他的工作，以至于他和妻子不得不推迟蜜月。最终，他们确实踏上了穿越欧洲前往意大利的旅程。他被科莫湖及其叉骨形状和阿尔卑斯山的背景所迷住。他既不是第一个，也不是最后一个被这景色迷住的人。这甚至是一个乔治·卢卡斯在
in one of the Star Wars movies when Padme and Anakin were getting together. We used to lie out on the sand and let the sun dry us and try to guess the names of the birds singing. I don't like sand. It's coarse. And he allegedly didn't use any CGI on that scene. William Henry Talbot wanted to capture the moment and share it with others, but it was the 19th century.
其中一部《星球大战》电影中使用的湖，当时帕德梅和阿纳金正走到一起。我们过去常躺在沙滩上，让太阳晒干我们，并试着猜那些唱歌的鸟的名字。我不喜欢沙子。它很粗糙。据称他在那个场景中没有使用任何CGI。威廉·亨利·塔尔博特想捕捉那一刻并与他人分享，但那是19世纪。
Cameras as we know them didn't exist. What he had was something called a camera lucida. Which is like, you know, a little device that you can use to kind of sketch things. It's kind of like the iPhone 11 of his time. And he made an amazing sketch, one that's very famous because he was very disappointed with his sketch. He allegedly said it was a melancholy to behold, which is not what you want to say about your honeymoon figures. And it caused him to start thinking about what it would be like, what technology could actually let images that he saw in his, in his version of a
我们所知的相机并不存在。他拥有的是一种叫做“暗箱”的东西。这就像，你知道，一种你可以用来描绘事物的小装置。它有点像他那个时代的iPhone 11。他画了一幅令人惊叹的素描，这幅素描非常出名，因为他对自己的素描非常失望。据称他说这看起来很忧郁，这不是你想在蜜月照片中说的话。这促使他开始思考，如果有什么技术能让他看到的图像，在他那个版本的
camera to stick on paper. And it led him to be one of the first developers of a lot of the photo technology that we use in, in real cameras today. William Henry Talbotts pioneering techniques in photography tell us something about how humans think We have an impulse to share with others what is going on in our heads our feelings our experiences our perspectives Laurie things this might be an important area of difference with other animals I think even if animals had had photographs they wouldn't use them You know if they had their iPhone 11, they wouldn't take pictures. And it's so funny when you realize that because that urge to share stuff is such a very
相机中，能够留在纸上会是什么样子。这使他成为我们今天在真正的相机中使用的许多照片技术的首批开发者之一。威廉·亨利·塔尔博特在摄影方面的开创性技术告诉我们人类是如何思考的。我们有一种冲动，想与他人分享我们脑海中正在发生的事情、我们的感受、我们的经历、我们的观点。劳里，这可能是与其他动物的一个重要区别领域。我认为即使动物有照片，它们也不会使用它们。你知道，如果它们有iPhone 11，它们也不会拍照。当你意识到这一点时，这太有趣了，因为那种分享东西的冲动是非常
human urge. It's one that researchers like Mike Thomas-Sello and colleagues find emerges within the first year of life. Babies are already starting to point at things and trying to get their parents to look. So it's a very, very fundamental urge. And remarkably, it seems to be one that's unique to humans. And you can see this so strikingly when you watch the behavior of mother primates and their kids.
人类的冲动。研究人员如迈克·托马斯-塞洛及其同事发现，这种冲动在生命的第一年内就会出现。婴儿已经开始指着东西，试图让父母看。所以这是一种非常非常基本的冲动。而且值得注意的是，这似乎是人类独有的。当你观察灵长类母亲及其孩子的行为时，你可以非常明显地看到这一点。
They just don't tend to show each other stuff. There's just not active teaching or even active like, hey, mom, look at this, look at me. They kind of just don't care. How do these differences reveal themselves in experiments, especially when it comes to certain mistakes that perhaps monkeys, chimps, and dogs don't make that humans do make? Well, I think one of the consequences of being a species that shares a lot of stuff is that we also are probably a species that believes a lot of stuff.
它们往往不会互相展示东西。它们之间没有主动的教学，甚至没有主动的“嘿，妈妈，看这个，看我”。它们似乎根本不在乎。这些差异在实验中是如何表现出来的，特别是在某些猴子、黑猩猩和狗不会犯而人类会犯的错误方面？嗯，我认为作为一个分享很多东西的物种，后果之一就是我们可能也是一个相信很多东西的物种。
You know, we want to share because it affects what others learn. And that suggests that we might be a species that can over-learn based on when we're getting information from others. In other words, we really are liable to believe the stuff that we're hearing from other individuals. That's why the sharing feels so powerful. But given that sharing is kind of in beta testing, it suggests that the learning might be in beta testing, too.
你知道，我们想要分享，因为它会影响他人学习什么。这表明我们可能是一个能够基于我们从他人那里获得信息而过度学习的物种。换句话说，我们确实很容易相信我们从其他人那里听到的东西。这就是为什么分享感觉如此强大。但考虑到分享正处于测试阶段，这表明学习可能也处于测试阶段。
And so the way that researchers have tried to test this is to ask whether or not humans are prone to over-learn when they get bad information from others. It's a tendency that researchers call over-imitation, the tendency to imitate too much. And so here's the study. You bring human children and chimpanzees into the lab. This is work done by Vicki Horner and her colleagues. And you give them access to a little puzzle box. In some cases, the puzzle box is opaque. It's hard to figure out how it opens up. But they get to see a human experimenter who helps them.
因此，研究人员试图测试这一点的方法是询问人类在从他人那里获得错误信息时是否容易过度学习。这是一种研究人员称之为“过度模仿”的倾向，即模仿过多的倾向。所以这就是这项研究。你把人类儿童和黑猩猩带进实验室。这是维基·霍纳及其同事所做的工作。你让他们接触一个小拼图盒。在某些情况下，拼图盒是不透明的。很难弄清楚它是怎么打开的。但他们可以看到一个帮助他们的人类实验者。
And the humaner experimenter does all these different actions on the box. You have to tap a lever at the top and stick a tool in and it's very, very elaborate. What you find is that when kids and chimpanzees see that, they copy pretty slavishly everything the human does. And that kind of copying makes sense because they don't know how to open the box.
而人类实验者在盒子上做了所有这些不同的动作。你必须敲击顶部的杠杆，插入一个工具，这非常非常复杂。你发现的是，当孩子和黑猩猩看到这些时，他们会非常盲目地复制人类所做的一切。那种复制是有道理的，因为他们不知道如何打开盒子。
But in a different condition, all that changes. Now you give kids and chimpanzees a transparent puzzle box. And because it's transparent, it's really obvious how to open it. There's just a door, and you open the door. There's nothing else in the box. The subjects also get to see this experiment are painstakingly trying to open the box,
但在另一种情况下，一切都变了。现在你给孩子和黑猩猩一个透明的拼图盒。因为它是透明的，所以打开它非常明显。只有一个门，你打开门。盒子里没有别的东西。受试者还可以看到这个实验者费尽心思地试图打开盒子，
using all these levers, using tools inside it and so on. But you can see those actions aren't doing anything. What you find is that the chimpanzees are pretty rational on this task. They completely ignore what the human did on the transparent box and just solve it in the really easy way. But sadly, perhaps for our species, human children don't do that. They slavishly follow everything they see the human doing.
使用所有这些杠杆，使用里面的工具等等。但你可以看到这些动作并没有起到任何作用。你发现的是，黑猩猩在这个任务上相当理性。它们完全忽略了人类在透明盒子上所做的事情，只是用非常简单的方式解决了它。但遗憾的是，也许对我们这个物种来说，人类儿童并没有那样做。他们盲目地模仿他们看到人类所做的一切。
They over imitate these actions, suggesting that when you see another individual doing something, especially intentionally, it messes up the way you think about the world, in the case of the children, it messes up the way you think about the world. In the case of the children, it messes up the way they think the box works. There's also been some work I think looking at a sort of child development, showing that when children are shown how a certain toy works a certain way, they become really, it's really difficult for them
他们过度模仿这些动作，这表明当你看到另一个人做某事时，尤其是故意做某事时，它会扰乱你对世界的思考方式，在儿童的情况下，它会扰乱你对世界的思考方式。在儿童的情况下，它会扰乱他们对盒子运作方式的思考。我还认为有一些研究观察了某种儿童发展，表明当儿童被展示某种玩具如何以某种方式工作时，他们变得非常，他们真的很难
to actually explore the toy and actually play with it in a different way, that they actually believe, okay, now I've been shown this is how the toy works, this is how I have to play with it. That's exactly right. This is some lovely work by Liz Bonowitch, which has shown that when children are taught something, it limits their exploration. So if they're given a puzzle box with lots of different knobs and interesting things,
去真正探索这个玩具并以不同的方式玩它，他们实际上相信，好吧，现在我已经看到了这个玩具是如何工作的，这就是我必须玩它的方式。那完全正确。这是利兹·博诺维奇的一些精彩工作，她表明当儿童被教导某事时，它会限制他们的探索。所以如果给他们一个有很多不同旋钮和有趣东西的拼图盒，
and a teacher comes and says, hey, here, this is how it works, and just presses one of the buttons. When children interact with that box, they'll just press that button. Even though all these other levers and cool things also make the toy do interesting stuff, kids never find it. And so it seems like teaching, we often think of as this wonderful thing, and of course it is, you know, of course this is the way we learn so much about our culture and how to do things in the world.
然后一位老师走过来说，嘿，看，这就是它的工作原理，然后只按了其中一个按钮。当孩子们与那个盒子互动时，他们只会按那个按钮。尽管所有这些其他杠杆和酷东西也让玩具做有趣的事情，但孩子们从未发现。所以看起来教学，我们通常认为这是一件美妙的事情，当然它确实是，你知道，当然这是我们学习关于我们的文化以及如何在世界上做事情的很多方式。
But there's a downside to it, which is that we don't have mechanisms to be critical about the things we're hearing from other humans. There's something humans do that's so intuitive, it's hard to even recognize that we're doing it. We can believe one thing, but can understand another person might believe something entirely different. Imagine that you ask a friend what day it is. She tells you it's the 21st. You check your calendar and realize it's actually the 20th. Your capable of
但它有一个缺点，那就是我们没有机制来批判我们从其他人那里听到的事情。人类做的一件事非常直观，以至于很难意识到我们正在这样做。我们可以相信一件事，但可以理解另一个人可能相信完全不同的事情。想象一下，你问一个朋友今天是几号。她告诉你今天是21号。你查看日历，意识到实际上是20号。你有能力
understanding that it is the 20th, but that your friend believes something else. We can constantly think about these cases where other people have misinformation. Otherwise, Romeo and Juliet would make no sense. Juliet didn't know that Romeo was alive and all these things that I forget for my high school English class, right? But this is the kind of thing we do all the time. We constantly can think about that other people have a different belief than us. We can think about past us and know that we had different beliefs than we do have now. We can think about future us and think, you know, I might have a different belief when I'm old and gray than when I do now. And so this is, it seems so easy because it comes so fluidly to us. But cognitively, this is really tricky.
理解今天是20号，但你的朋友相信别的东西。我们可以不断地思考这些其他人有错误信息的情况。否则，罗密欧与朱丽叶就毫无意义了。朱丽叶不知道罗密欧还活着，以及所有我在高中英语课上忘记的事情，对吧？但这正是我们一直在做的事情。我们不断地可以思考其他人有与我们不同的信念。我们可以思考过去的我们，知道我们曾经有与现在不同的信念。我们可以思考未来的我们，想，你知道，当我老了、头发花白时，我可能会有与现在不同的信念。所以这看起来很容易，因为它在我们身上流动得如此顺畅。但在认知上，这真的很棘手。
It means I have to maintain this like representation, this information about the world that I know is really true, versus at the same time knowing that somebody else thinks something different. It's kind of a hard task when you think about it. You know, when you think about the movies, for example, the movies wouldn't work if we didn't have this skill. I'm thinking about the famous shower scene in Psycho, you know, as a member of the audience, you know that the murderer is about to kill the woman in the shower, but the woman in the shower doesn't know this. And of course that increases your fear and anxiety about what's happening, not just because you know a murder is about a take place But because you know the victim doesn't know that a murder is about a take place
这意味着我必须保持这种表征，这种关于我知道是真实的世界的信息，同时知道别人认为不同的东西。当你想到它时，这是一个相当困难的任务。你知道，当你想到电影时，例如，如果我们没有这种技能，电影就不会奏效。我正在思考《惊魂记》中著名的淋浴场景，你知道，作为观众的一员，你知道凶手即将杀死淋浴中的女人，但淋浴中的女人不知道这一点。当然，这增加了你对正在发生的事情的恐惧和焦虑，不仅因为你知道谋杀即将发生，还因为你知道受害者不知道谋杀即将发生。
That's exactly right and beyond that, you know Another feature of this ability that we have is you know, it allows us to do fiction at all You know like you know that there's a murder about to take place But it's not in your house like you can represent that there's a separation between you and what you know in the moment and other people's representations, other people's beliefs. So it's a really fundamental capacity and that's one of the reasons that researchers have been so interested in whether or not non-human animals can do this. How do we solve this hard computational problem?
那完全正确，除此之外，你知道我们拥有的这种能力的另一个特点是，你知道，它允许我们进行虚构。你知道，就像你知道有一场谋杀即将发生，但它不在你家里，就像你可以表征你和你此刻所知道的与他人的表征、他人的信念之间存在分离。所以这是一种非常基本的能力，这也是研究人员对非人类动物是否能做到这一点如此感兴趣的原因之一。我们如何解决这个困难的计算问题？
Do we need language to solve it? You know, is this the kind of thing other species can look at? Testing this, though, is pretty tricky, because you have to be able to ask whether or not a monkey knows that some other person has a false belief. And it's hard because they can't tell you. Luckily, we have different tricks we can use to test it. And one of those tricks is kind of using
我们需要语言来解决它吗？你知道，这是其他物种可以观察的事情吗？然而，测试这一点非常棘手，因为你必须能够询问猴子是否知道某人有错误的信念。这很难，因为它们无法告诉你。幸运的是，我们可以使用不同的技巧来测试它。其中一个技巧是使用
the same type of study we use to look at what monkeys know about other perspectives. These kinds of studies were monkeys see people acting we use to look at what monkeys know about other perspectives. These kinds of studies where monkeys see people acting in different ways based on what they know, but in this case, we can ask how monkeys expect people to behave based on their belief. And here's the situation, you know, we just use this example of me having the false belief
我们用来观察猴子对其他观点了解程度的相同类型的研究。这些研究中，猴子看到人们根据他们所知道的以不同方式行事，我们用来观察猴子对其他观点了解程度。这些研究中，猴子看到人们根据他们所知道的以不同方式行事，但在这种情况下，我们可以询问猴子如何根据人们的信念预期他们的行为。这就是情况，你知道，我们刚刚使用了我关于下雨的错误信念的例子。
about it raining. You know, so imagine I think it's raining out in New Haven. You might have certain predictions about my behavior. You might expect me to take an umbrella and be surprised, you know, if I went out in like, you know, shoes that weren't appropriate for the rain, that would surprise you, because you know something about my belief, even though that belief is false. That was basically the logic we used to set up a study with monkeys. Monkeys get to watch as a person is looking for an object that she really wants
你知道，所以想象一下我认为纽黑文外面正在下雨。你可能对我的行为有某些预测。你可能期望我带一把伞，并感到惊讶，你知道，如果我穿着不适合雨天的鞋子出去，那会让你感到惊讶，因为你知道关于我信念的一些事情，即使那个信念是错误的。这基本上是我们用来设置猴子研究的逻辑。猴子看着一个人在寻找她真正想要的对象
in the world. And the monkeys get to watch this object rolling back and forth between two boxes, a left box and a right box. So at this point the monkey should be thinking, oh, the person's going to reach into the left box. But then all of a sudden the person gets covered up. She's not paying attention anymore. And the monkey gets his own private access to the fact that the object that the person wants then rolls into the right side box. So the monkey knows where it's really, but the question is whether or not the monkey recognizes that the person shouldn't know where it is, that the person should have a false belief. If the monkey gets that, he should be surprised
在世界上。猴子看着这个物体在两个盒子之间来回滚动，一个左盒子和一个右盒子。所以此时猴子应该在想，哦，那个人会伸手去拿左边的盒子。但突然间，那个人被遮住了。她不再注意了。猴子获得了他自己私下的访问权，知道那个人想要的对象随后滚到了右边的盒子里。所以猴子知道它真正在哪里，但问题是猴子是否意识到那个人不应该知道它在哪里，那个人应该有一个错误的信念。如果猴子明白了这一点，他应该会感到惊讶
if the person reaches to where the object really is, because she shouldn't know that she should have a false belief. But interestingly, that's not what we find. What we find is that the monkey seem to make no prediction in that case. And what this tells us, which is so cool, is it tells us that the monkey has realized the person's perspective is different from their own,
如果那个人伸手去拿物体真正所在的地方，因为她不应该知道，她应该有一个错误的信念。但有趣的是，我们并没有发现这一点。我们发现的是，猴子在那种情况下似乎没有做出任何预测。这告诉我们，这太酷了，它告诉我们猴子已经意识到那个人的观点与他们自己的不同，
but they can't simulate what it is. In other words, they know, while she doesn't know what I know, like that's why they don't really have a prediction about where she should act. They don't think she should reach for the object. But they can't really simulate this other belief. So this is so fascinating because when you think about what the monkeys were doing on the island of Puerto Rico and they're basically saying this person has her back turned to me so it's going to be easier to steal a fruit from
但他们无法模拟它是什么。换句话说，他们知道，虽然她不知道我知道什么，就像这就是为什么他们对她应该在哪里行动没有真正的预测。他们不认为她应该伸手去拿那个物体。但他们无法真正模拟这种其他信念。所以这太迷人了，因为当你想到猴子在波多黎各岛上所做的事情时，他们基本上是在说这个人背对着我，所以从这个人身上偷水果会比面对我的人更容易。在某种程度上，猴子能够说我有一种感觉，背对着我的人知道的比面对我的人少。所以他们对实验者头脑中正在发生的事情或实验者的知识有一些表征感，但这在实验中并没有转化为你对实验者信念的思考，或者这两个场景之间的区别是什么？是的，区别在于猴子仅仅认为“哦，那个人什么都不知道”与“那个人有非常具体的信念”的情况，对吧？当你
this person and the person who is facing me. At some level the monkey is able to say I have a sense that the person who's back is toward me knows less than the person who is faces toward me. So they have some sense of representation of what's happening inside the experimenter's mind or the experimenter's knowledge but that doesn't translate in this experiment into what you think about the beliefs of the experiment, or what's the distinction between those two scenarios? Yeah, the distinction is between a case where the monkeys simply think, oh, that person doesn't know anything versus that person has a very specific belief, right? And when you
回到你使用的例子，那种淋浴的例子，那个非常可怕的例子，猴子可能对那个场景有同样的直觉和同样的反应。它们可能知道那个人不知道杀手要来了。但它们可能无法表征的是那个人自己相信什么。
get back to the example you used, the kind of the shower example, the really scary example, the monkeys might have the same intuition and the same reaction to that scene that we do. They would probably know the person doesn't know that a killer is coming. But what they might not be able to represent is what the person themselves does believe.
他们相信他们在淋浴中是安全的，你知道，什么都不会发生，他们会没事的。就像，猴子似乎无法模拟那个人知道的所有事情，但猴子自己却不知道。他们知道此时此地的现实，但他们无法模拟超越现实的事情。
They believe they're safe in the shower, You know, that nothing's gonna happen, that they're gonna be in their fine. Like, the monkeys seem to not be able to simulate all the things that the person knows, but that the monkey himself doesn't know. They know reality in the here and now, but they can't kind of simulate things that go beyond reality.
你知道，别人的信念在现实中不是真的，甚至，你知道，我们在未来会想什么，或者我们在过去想什么，甚至反事实的情况，那些在此时此地不是真的，但在理论上可能是真的事情。那些不是猴子似乎能够模拟的关于世界的情况。那不是它们似乎能够表征的事情。但如果你考虑到这有多关键，不仅要知道某人有不同的观点，还要知道那个观点是什么，这在很多方面确实是人类认知的核心。
You know, someone else's belief that's not true of reality now, or even, you know, what we're gonna think in the future or what we thought in the past, even counterfactual situations, things that aren't true in the here and now, but in theory could be true. Those aren't situations about the world that the monkeys seem to be able to simulate. That's not the kind of thing they seem to be able to represent. But if you think about how critical that is, not just to know someone has a different perspective, but to know what that perspective is, it really is the crux of human cognition in so many ways.
所以其他动物似乎没有这一点，这很迷人。我想探索最后一个差异领域，这与价格如何塑造人类和其他动物的感知有关。当你提高一个物体的价格时，人类和其他动物如何反应？是的，嗯，这是另一个我们实际上假设我们会看到猴子和人类在这方面相似的地方，但这是我们在经济领域中看到这些巨大差异的少数几个地方之一。人类对价格有各种各样的理论，但我们拥有的理论之一是更
So it's fascinating that other animals seem not to have this. There's one last area of difference I want to explore, which has to do with how price shapes the perceptions of humans and other animals. How do humans and other animals respond when you raise the price of an object? Yeah, well this was another spot where we actually assumed we would see similarity between monkeys and humans in this respect, but it was one of the few spots in the economic domain where we saw these big differences. Humans have all kinds of theories about price, but one of the theories we have is that more
昂贵的东西更好。这就是为什么当新款iPhone出来时，它通常比旧款iPhone更贵。这让人觉得它更有价值。这就是为什么人们对非常非常昂贵的葡萄酒感到兴奋，想要尝试，不一定是因为它一定更好，但人们假设它会尝起来更好。事实上，有一些神经科学研究表明，你可以改变人们大脑奖励区域的放电模式，仅仅通过给他们同样的葡萄酒并对他们撒谎，告诉他们它更贵。
expensive things are better. This is why when a new iPhone comes out, it's often more expensive than the old iPhone. That makes people think it's a lot more valuable. It's one of the reasons that very, very expensive wine people are all excited to try it, not necessarily because it's necessarily better, but people assume it's going to taste better. In fact, there's some neuroscience work that you can change the pattern of firing in the reward areas of people's brains, merely by giving them the same wine and lying to them and telling them it was more expensive.
所以这似乎是我们处理价格的一种基本方式。我们假设更昂贵的东西一定更好。所以我们在我们的猴子市场中有一个很好的方法来测试这一点。我们可以仅仅通过改变我们给猴子的食物量来改变商品的价格，所以我们可以给他们一大块某种食物作为他们的代币美元，这有点像用一美元买到一大块巧克力，或者我们可以给他们一小块食物。就像你用一美元买到的昂贵巧克力的微小松露，对吧？所以我们可以训练他们，然后给他们一个情况，让他们决定他们想要哪一个，而不必支付。所以这就是模型。你知道，想象一下你学会了，你知道，用一美元，你得到A品牌的
So this seems to be a basic way that we approach price. We assume that more expensive things have to be better. And so we had this great way to test that in our monkey market. We could change the price of goods merely by altering the amount of food we gave monkeys, so we could give them a really, really huge piece of one kind of food for their token dollar, which would kind of be like getting a brand of chocolate that's like really enormous for a dollar, or we could give them a really, really tiny piece of food. It's like the teeny, tiny truffle of expensive chocolate that you get for a one dollar, right? And so we could train them on this and then give them a situation where they got to just decide which of those they wanted without having to pay. And so that's kind of the model. You know, imagine you learn, you know, for one dollar, you get brand A of
巧克力，它是一大块，你知道，可能没那么好。而用另一美元，你得到B品牌的巧克力，那是一小块巧克力。现在你去参加招待会，这两种巧克力都在那里，你知道，免费摆着。你知道，你追求哪一个？这基本上就是我们给他们的。一个关键是他们有一个免费喂食条件，他们可以抓取他们想要的任何东西。令我们惊讶的是，他们似乎根本不在乎。
chocolate and it's this huge enormous piece, you know, probably not that good. And for another dollar, you get brand B of chocolate and that is a teeny, teeny, tiny piece of chocolate. Now you go to a reception and both of those kinds of chocolates are out there, you know, sitting for free. You know, which do you go after? That was basically what we gave them. One key is they had a free feeding condition where they could grab whatever they wanted. And to our surprise, they just didn't seem to care.
这令人震惊，因为在所有其他研究中，他们向我们展示了他们非常关心价格。你知道，他们是这些很棒的精明购物者，但他们没有成为我们对价格表现出的这种偏见的牺牲品。他们没有不理性地认为价格更高的商品会尝起来更好。所以，换句话说，我听到你说的是，你可以在猴子的世界里建立一个好市多，但可能建立不了一个米其林三星餐厅。那完全正确，特别是一个实际上并没有
Which was shocking because in all other studies, they showed us that they cared about price a lot. You know, they were these wonderful bargain shoppers, but they didn't fall prey to this bias that we show about price. They didn't irrationally think that higher priced goods were going to taste better. So, in other words, what I'm hearing you say is that you could set up a Costco in the world of monkeys, but probably not a three Michelin star restaurant. And that's exactly right, especially a three Michelin star restaurant that didn't actually
好食物的米其林三星餐厅。所以，你刚才指出的许多人类与其他动物之间的差异似乎与我们与社会世界的关系有关，我们如何想要与他人分享想法，我们如何直觉地感知别人头脑中正在发生的事情，我们如何强烈地关心别人对我们的看法。这些差异可能导致人类所做的一些最好的事情，但也导致人类所做的一些最坏的事情，这太有趣了。是的，这是我发现关于这些发现最迷人的事情之一，即那些使我们与众不同的事情，不仅允许人类做我们所做的一些最聪明的事情，你知道，建立这些五星级餐厅，你理解丰富的虚构和电影，
have good food. So, many of the differences you've just identified between humans and other animals seem to be connected to the way we relate to our social worlds, how we want to share ideas with other people, how we intuit what's happening inside someone else's mind, how we care intensely about what others think of us. It's so interesting that these differences might be responsible for some of the best things that humans do, but also some of the worst things that humans do. Yeah, that's one of the things I find most fascinating about these findings is that the things that make us different, not only allow humans to do some of the smartest things we do, you know, set up these five-star restaurants, you understand rich fiction and movies,
但它们也让我们做一些彻头彻尾的愚蠢事情。你知道，我认为我们确定的偏见与导致假新闻如此容易传播的偏见是一样的。它们也是导致我们喜欢在可能没那么好的东西上花很多钱的相同类型的事情。你知道，所以令人惊讶的是，那些使我们如此特别和如此聪明的事情在某些情况下也可以让我们看起来有点笨。劳里·桑托斯是耶鲁大学心理学和认知科学教授。她是播客《幸福实验室》的主持人。劳里，感谢你今天加入我们的《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。
but they also make us do some downright dumb stuff You know, I think that the biases we've identified are the same biases that result in fake news being spread so easily They also are the same kinds of things that cause us to like spend lots of money on stuff that's probably not that good You know, so it's remarkable that the the very things that make us so special and so smart can also in some context make us seem kind of dumb. Laurie Santos is a professor of psychology and cognitive science at Yale University. She is the host of the podcast, The Happiness Lab. Laurie, thanks for joining us today on Hidden Break. Thanks so much.
本集由雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括帕特·邵、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔。我们本周的无名英雄是安迪·胡塔。安迪是NPR的音频工程师。他一直在帮助我们完成向新音频编辑软件系统的过渡。当你像安迪一样精通音频编辑时，
This episode was produced by Raina Cohen, and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Pat Shao, Thomas Liu, and Laura Quarell. Our unsung hero this week is Andy Huta. Andy is an audio engineer at NPR. He's been helping us make the transition to a new audio editing software system. When you're as skilled at audio editing as Andy is,
很容易成为知识诅咒的牺牲品，忘记不知道某事是什么感觉。但安迪完全理解如何向从零开始的人解释概念。他很有耐心，总是愿意花时间回答我们的问题。谢谢你，安迪。欲了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这个节目，请告诉一位朋友本集中你认为
it's easy to fall prey to the curse of knowledge, to forget what it's like to not know something. But Andy understands exactly how to explain concepts to people who are starting from square one. He's patient and always willing to make time to answer our questions. Thanks Andy. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you enjoyed the show, please tell one friend about an idea in the episode
让你大开眼界的想法。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
that you found eye-opening. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
让你大开眼界。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。